This first question requires a bit of explanation,
so bare with me here. The goal of
this question is to find an app on
a Play Store that has low ratings. Then, we're
going to estimate how much of that low rating
came from violated constraints. So the way we're going to
do this is by going to the Google
Play store. And we're going to find an app with
a relatively low review. Let's say below three and
half stars. So I just clicked on this app. Looks
like it has a review of about three and
a half stars. And notice if I scroll down, I
can see what the actual average rating is. But
I can also see were that rating came from. 720
five star reviews, 310 one star, and so on. But
beyond that I can also click into the individual reviews.
>From this page I can look at reviews
by Newest, Helpfulness or Rating, which will be especially
helpful for this exercise. And then I can
read individual reviews. Apparently this person's upset that this
app requires camera and microphone permission. In this
question you're actually going to read a lot of
reviews with different star ratings of an app that
has an overall pretty low rating. And as you
read you're going to pay attention to how many
of these reviews reference violated mobile constraints, as a reason
for the low rating. As you read these reviews,
you're going to be filling out this table. So the
rows represent the number of stars, and this column
is the total number of reviews with this star rating.
This column is where you'll keep track of the
total number of reviews you read with that star rating.
So, let's say you had looked at five one
star reviews and three those had violated mobile constraints. You're
going to go through this table, fill out all of
these fifteen boxes, and at the end when you hit
submit, over on the right side here where you
get your feed back the apps current rating will be
calculated. You should already know that but his will
be a sanity check. It's predicted rating, if no mobile
constraints had been violated, will be calculated as
well. Now this prediction is of course a prediction,
it's an estimate, and it comes from the assumption
that one, the reviews you read were somehow representative
of people who gave one star reviews or two
star reviews. But, also there are some assumptions baked
in about, well, if you'd given it a one
star review and said there was a violated constraint.
You probably would of given it a three or four star review, had
there been no constraint violated. You can
read more about those assumptions in the
instructor notes, and if you have any questions, I understand this is a
bit of a confusing question, feel free to post them in the discussion forum.